What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience,
did many people have a concern that someone else is going to do what we're not
willing to do first?
Yes.
Right.
They're worried.
China and Russia,
those are the big ones.
especially China.
Yeah.
They're very technologically advanced.
And their innovations off the chain when it comes to like walk away,
just recently surpassed apples,
the number to a cell phone manufacturer in the world five years ago,
they had some like a single digit share of the marketplace.
Now they're number two on the planet earth.
I mean they,
they hustle and if they just decide to make super people and they,
they do it before we do.
That's what people were worried about right there where they're worried about
there's trivial things were seemingly trivial like athletics.
And then there's things that are really like,
what,
who,
what's to stop people from just becoming the hulk?
What's to stop people from becoming a mortal?
What's the style?
What is,
well,
two questions.
First is,
is um,
China is,
I think it's a really big issue.
The 21st,
the story of the 21st century.
One of the biggest stories of the 21st century will be how the US China rivalry
plays out.
And the playing field will be with these revolutionary technologies.
And China has a national plan to lead the world and these technologies,
by 2050,
they're putting huge resources.
They have really smart people.
They are really focused on that.
And it's a big deal in genetic technologies.
Um,
uh,
when last year of the new book hacking dorm was already in production in
November when it was announced at these first genetically engineered babies had
been born in China.
And so I called the publisher and say,
we need to pull this back out of production because I need to reference this,
but it didn't require much of a chain because I had already written this is
happening.
We're going to see the world's first gene edited humans.
It's going to happen first in China.
And here's why.
So I just had a,
had a,
had to add a few sentences saying,
and it just happened in October of,
uh,
of 2018.
So China is on that path and we need to recognize that on one hand the United
States needs to be competitive.
On the other hand,
we don't want a runaway arms race of the human race.
And that's why we need to find this balance between national ambition,
uh,
and some kind of of global rules.
But it's really hard to do.
Yeah.
And the other thing is that we're competing with them.
And so if they decide to do at first were almost compelled to do it second or
compelled to try to keep up.
Yeah.
How far away do you think we are from physically manipulating living human
beings versus fetuses versus,
yeah,
so physically manipulating living human beings,
we are there.
So yeah.
Yeah.
So that's may often it's called gene therapy.
So for example,
there's a whole class of,
of treatments for,
uh,
for treating cancer called car t therapy.
So you have a cancer.
When you're younger,
your body is better able to fight cancers.
Um,
what you can do some of that cancer,
you take their cells,
you give there,
you manipulate their cells to give them cancer fighting superpowers.
And you put them back into the person's body and now the person's body behaves
like you're a younger person.
You have the ability to fight back.
So gene therapies are already happening,
or relatively small number of them have already been approved,
but there is a list of thousands of them with the regulators in applications to
regulators around the world.
So that the era of Jim making genetic changes to living humans that's already
here.
Like what can they do with it?
So far?
So,
so far,
most of it is focused on treating diseases.
Um,
but a lot more is a,
is coming because when people think about the,
the human,
the genome,
our genome isn't a disease genome.
It's not a healthcare gene and genome.
It's a human genome.
And so we are going to be able to do things that feel like cr crazy things like
changing people's eye color,
changing people's skin color to funky things.
I mean,
there's a lot of stuff that we're not doing now that we will be,
uh,
be able to do it.
[inaudible].